Can.
The Ukrainian
Air Force tonight is falling
just short
of claiming
official responsibility
for yet another drone strike
deep inside Russian territory.
But they're certainly not denying
it either.
A spokesperson for the Air Force
Air Force saying, quote,
This is just a consequence
of what Russia is doing,
which is the relentless bombardment
of civilian infrastructure
targets that cause
rolling blackouts
affecting millions of people
across this country
in the dead of winter.
Now, as far as this latest drone strike
in the western port city of Engels,
which is along the Volga River
around 500 miles southeast of Moscow,
we know that at least
three Russian servicemen
were killed on Monday.
And we also know
this is the second attempted
drone attack on this area,
which includes a strategic bomber airbase
Now, Russian state media is claiming
that this drone was shot down.
We cannot independently verify
that claim.
Meanwhile, in Moscow,
President Putin is
well, he's certainly
getting a lot of skepticism,
not just here in Ukraine,
but around the world for his offer
that is believed here
in Ukraine to be disingenuous,
to negotiate to an end to this war, talk
about acceptable solutions in his words.
Adviser to President
Zelensky says that Moscow
doesn't really want to negotiate.
They just want to avoid responsibility
for their continuing
attacks on civilians,
that Ukraine says warrants them
being kicked out of the United Nations
and the United Nations Security Council,
where they're a permanent member
with veto power, one of five.
There's actually no
mechanism written
into the UN Charter to remove them.
So that is more of a political statement
than an actual possibility at this stage,
although the Ukrainians
would certainly like
to see some consequences at the U.N.
for Russia,
because essentially
they have the power
to veto any resolutions against them.
Meanwhile, here in Kiev,
President Alinsky
calling for patience
and faith
from the Ukrainian people
and warning that there could be
some difficult and dark days ahead.
When he gave his Christmas address,
he warned of the potential
of Russian retaliation.
Of course,
he didn't mention the drone strike,
but in general,
the Ukrainians are worried
that there could be
some sort of major Russian attack
before the end of the year
after a brief pause over Christmas.
And Dmitri Medvedev
the former president of Ukraine,
he is saying that Russia
will engage in this war
until, quote, the disgusting,
almost fascist
regime in
Kiev is both removed
and demilitarize eyes,
which certainly is very different
language from President
Putin saying he's
willing to negotiate power.
All right, Will Ripley,
thank you so much.
And more perspective now
from CNN military analyst
and retired Army
Lieutenant General Mark Hertling.
General Hertling.
You heard that report
there from Will Ripley.
What is your reaction
to this new strike on an air base
deep inside Russian territory?
Let's call it what
it is, Pam
Angles to air base
near the city of Sacra,
about 400 kilometers away
from the front line,
has several
important factors regarding its.
This has been an effective
operational target
now twice for the Ukrainian military.
And it's important
for about four reasons.
First, it shows Russia
they have no safe haven
and they must defend their facilities
wherever they are.
Secondly,
it shows Ukraine has a strike capability
that Russia didn't know about Third,
and most importantly
and goes to
is the base for the T u one 60 aircraft.
That's something called
the backfire bomber.
And that airplane
has a standoff capability and
it's able to launch
multiple cruise missiles.
These are the missiles
that have been launched
from outside the territory of Ukraine
to affect the infrastructure
within Ukraine.
And that's why Ukraine is targeting.
But finally, the most important part.
There is reports tonight
that these aircraft have now been moved
further to the east and Russia 4000
miles away from the
from the Ukrainian border.
That's three time zones.
And if so, it will require Russia
to launch those aircraft,
use a lot more fuel
and be able to be picked up.
So it's they're all critically important.
So that is the practical military effect.
Meantime, you have Vladimir Putin
saying on Sunday
that he is ready to, quote,
negotiate with everyone involved
in this process
about acceptable solutions, end quote.
With regard to the war in Ukraine.
You have actually,
what should we say,
quote, negotiated with Russians.
What did that experience tell you
about Putin's intentions here?
Yeah, well,
I certainly haven't negotiated with Mr.
Putin himself,
but I have
negotiated with some of his military
officers, his generals
and some of his Ministry
of Defense officials.
And what I will tell you is this.
I learned valuable lessons, Pamela.
First of all, they lie.
Secondly,
they will never negotiate
evenly And thirdly,
if they do finally negotiate
and you think you have a deal,
they will renege on that deal.
And what's important about this,
all of our European allies know this.
And it seems
the Americans are slow to learn this,
that it's just not a good thing
to negotiate with Putin,
because he lies, he detracts
and he reneges on any deal that he makes.
Ukraine, as we as well
pointed out,
is calling for Russia
to be excluded from the U.N..
What do you make of that?
Yeah, I'm
not going
to comment on that
because that's something
for the politicians to decide.
But I've also seen reports from
from CNN reporters
saying that's
going to be very difficult to do because
the Soviet Union, not Russia,
the Soviet Union
was one of the founding members
of the U.N.
and because of
that was one of the five original members
that makes up that.
But it's going to be tough
to kick them off
because they have a veto vote.
They can just veto anybody
that tries to kick them off
that Security Council.